so there are two things that keep me
motivated in my day to day life running
incubator the first is the knowledge
that we face some incredible challenges
on our planet today around wastes energy
consumption rising co2 levels and
agricultural droughts and then the other
thing that keeps me motivated is the
passion excitement hope and dedication
my team which is working to solve those
problems with me around our technology
thank you so I'm sort of motivated by
the first one through I guess fear or
the desire to effect a change and I'm
motivated by the second one by all the
passion I find around me with my team
and also all the wonderful people i'm
meeting here at Davos yeah